يعقد قاده دول مجموعه سبعه صناعيه الكبرى
اجتماعهم السنوي في مدينه هيروشيما
باليابان اليوم الجمعه
حتى يوم الاحد
انيا وتحديات الاقتصاد العالمي والامني في
منطقه المحيطين الهندي والهادئ
وكاله الانباء اليابانيه فيديو لقاده دول
المجموعه وهم يضعون اكليل الزهور على نصب
التذكاري للقنبله الذريه في حديقه السلام
بهيروشيما خلال افتتاح القمه المقابل بس
انه
شطاطس كل مقاطع فيديو لخ روج مات في مدينه
هيروشيما احتجاجا على استضافه
القمه اتفق قاده مجموعه السبع على فرض
عقوبات جديده ضد روسيا بهدف حرمانها من
التكنولوجيا والمعدات الصناعيه التي تدعم
قدرتها العسكريه تشمل العقوبات قيودا على
المواد وكيانات توصف بانها مهمه في حرب
روسيا على اوكرانيا هذا وكانت القمه قد
جددت التزامها بدعم اوكرانيا مليا وعسكريا
ودبلوماسيا
واضاف بيان المجموعه ان السلامه في
اوكرانيا لا يمكن تحقيقه دون انسحاب كامل
وغير مشروط للقوات الروسيه كما قالت الدول
في بيانها انها تعول في نجاحها على منع
روسيا من استخدام الطاقه سلاحا ضدها وضد
العالم باسره
معنا من هيروشيما باليابان مراسله جزيره
محمد البقالي اذا محمد قمه هامه موضوع
الحرب في اوكرانيا من احد ملفاتها ولكن
ايضا هناك البعد
الصيني فيما يتعلق بالملفات الهامه
المدرجه في هذه القمه
بالفعل عبد القادر هناك مواضيع كثيره في
الحقيقه في هذه القمه لكن الموضوعين
البارزين على جدول الاعمال هو هما الموضوع
الاوكراني والموضوع الصيني بالنسبه
لاوكرانيا القمه لديها توجه واضح هو اولا
تجديد الضغط على روسيا رفع مزيد من
العقوبات وفرض عقوبات جديده بالاضافه الى
مساله بحث صيغ محاربه التفاف مع ما سمي
بالتفاف روسيا حول العقوبات المفروضه سلفا
بالنسبه للعقوبات الجديده بيان قمه السبع
الذي صدر بهذا الشان يؤكد بانها ستشمل
قطاعات جديده ستشمل ايضا حرمان السوق
الروسيه من كل الصادرات التي يمكن ان تعزز
قوتها في ساحه المعركه وتشمل ايضا كل ما
يمكن ان يعزز قدرتها الماليه التي يمكن ان
تذهب لتمويل اله الحرب وفقا
التصريحات لتصريحات قمه السبعه وفي هذا
السياق استمعنا لرئيس المجلس الاوروبي
الذي يتحدث عن فرض عقوبات جديده حتى على
قطاع الماء الالماس وهو قطاع يدر على
الخزينه الروسيه ما بين خمسه الى سته
مليارات دولار سنويا بمعنى ان هناك رغبه
ونيه من اجل تجفيف منابع تمويل الحرب
الروسيه ثم رغبه من اجل ايضا المزيد من
الضغط على روسيا لاقناعها بعدم جدوى هذه
الحرب وبعدم تمكنها من النصر هذا بالاضافه
الى مساله البحث عن الصيغ لمنع ما سمي
بالالتفاف الروسي حول هذه العقوبات لانه
هناك قناعه داخل قمه السبع وداخل الاتحاد
الاوروبي بان الحزم التي تم ارساؤها من
العقوبات لم تعطي نتائج كافيه لحد اللحظه
عشر حزم من العقوبات تم فرضها على روسيا
والسبب او على الاقل من بين الاسباب هو ما
سمي بالثغرات التي تشمل هذه العقوبات بحيث
عن طريق دول ثالثه بحيث ان روسيا تتمكن من
اختراق هذه العقوبات ومن الحصول على
المواد التي هي بموجب هذه العقوبات محرومه
منها وتتمكن من التصدير وغير ذلك وذلك عن
طريق شركات ودول ثالثه وتم تسميه بعض
الدول من بينها ارمينيا
وايران والصين وعدد من الشركات وبالتالي
فهذا هو الاتجاه الان الاتجاه من جهه
لتجديد العقوبات ومن جهه ثانيه الى محاوله
اغلاق الثغرات التي يمكن ان يتم من خلالها
الالتفاف حول هذه العقوبات وقد كان لافتا
حديث احد الدبلوماسيين الفرنسيين من
الاليزي قال بان هذه العقوبات لديها تاثير
سلبي ايضا على الاقتصاديات الاوروبيه
وبالتالي لا يمكن ان تتاثر الاقتصاديات
الاوروبيه سلبا وفي النهايه لا يكون الوجع
الروسي
قدر التاثر تاثر الاقتصاديات الاوروبيه من
هذه العقوبات اذا على هذا الامر ليبدو انه
لا خلاف والاتفاق قد تم ويبدو ان الامور
تسير في هذا الاتجاه بالنسبه للصين لو
سمحت عبد القادر
المؤتمر او القمه تتم تحت عنوان عريض هو
توحيد الموقف موقف دول السبع في مواجهه
الصين مع ملاحظه ان الفرنسيين والاوروبيين
يركزون على ان هذه القمه ليست قمه مواجهه
مع الصين وانما هي قمه دعوه الصين الى
الحوار ولكن وفق اشتراطات شديده هناك اولا
الدعوه للصين للقيام بدور وممارسه النفود
من اجل وقف الحرب الروسيه وايضا دعوه اخرى
للصين من اجل ما سمي بوقف
باذن الله سنتابع في معك هذه القمه من
هيروشيما محمد البقالي شكرا جزيلا لك